the impeachment inquiry against
President Trump is moving to the next
phase after defiant testimony from the
final public witnesses former White
House official Fiona Hill and State
Department staffer David Holmes
recounted specific conversations
implicating the president and a scheme
to pressure Ukraine to investigate his
political rivals and he'll issued a
stark warning about push about pushing
what he says when she says rather is a
fictional narrative that only benefits
Russia House Speaker Nancy Pelosi says
the evidence is clear that the president
violated his oath of office but the
president says he did nothing wrong and
the White House is now saying that he
would welcome a Senate trial if he's
impeached in the house Nancy Cordes is
on Capitol Hill for us where lawmakers
have questioned 17 witnesses and looked
at more than 3000 pages of sworn
depositions so Nancy good morning what
comes next
well there are no more public hearing
scheduled Tony Democrats tell us they do
believe that they have the evidence they
need to move forward and so the House
Intelligence Committee which held all
these hearings will now spend the next
week or two writing up a report sending
it to the House Judiciary Committee
which would then draft articles of
impeachment this impeach a Palooza tour
finally comes to an end two weeks one
dozen witnesses and one basic story it
was inappropriate
I found the July 25th phone call unusual
was there a quid pro quo the answer is
yes they said the Ukrainians were told
again and again president Solinsky would
not get a meeting with President Trump
or millions in military aid unless he
announced certain investigations the
statement should include specific
reference to Purisima and 2016 by this
point it was clear that BER yzma was
code for the Biden's on Thursday former
White House official fiona hill said she
saw the pressure campaign up close did
you go speak to the lawyer's I certainly
did she said a Ukrainian delegation
visiting the White House was informed of
the ultimatum by US ambassador to the EU
Gordon Sunland he was being involved in
a domestic political arrant and we were
being involved in national security
foreign policy and
two things had just diverged I did say
to him ambassador Sunland Gordon I think
this is all going to blow up and here we
are half a world away in Ukraine embassy
official David Holmes overheard a
conversation between Sandland and mr.
Trump a couple weeks later I then heard
president Trump ask so he's going to do
the investigation ambassador songline
replied that he's going to do it adding
that President Solinsky will do anything
you ask him to do he'll is a Russia
expert and warned that the Ukraine
controversy is playing right into
Putin's hands some of you on this
committee appear to believe that Russia
and its security services did not
conduct a campaign against our country
and that perhaps somehow for some reason
Ukraine did this is a fictional
narrative looking ahead to a possible
Senate trial president Trump met
Thursday with key GOP senators notably
frequent Trump critic Mitt Romney and
Maine's Susan Collins when it gets to
the Senate we're gonna do it we're gonna
do it right now everybody's gonna have
their day in court
Democrats argued Senate Republicans
shouldn't discuss impeachment with the
president he's trying to taint the jury
pool and they should be above it one
Republican senator who was at that White
House meeting Lindsey Graham told us
afterwards that White House officials
still seem to believe that there's a
better than 50/50 chance that
impeachment won't go through in the
house but based on what we are hearing
from Democrats right now Anthony that
seems highly optimistic all right Nancy
thank you